all right welcome to the stream it's
been a while since I've streamed on
YouTube totally new set up I've been
streaming a bunch on Twitch and as many
of you know the last YouTube streams
were when I was trying to do the live
CNN debate coverage and CNN shut me down
and their VP said all sorts of stuff
about me a VP of PR or communication or
some things had all sorts of stuff
anyway then we were on vacation I'm back
on YouTube and I'm gonna be doing twitch
stuff and YouTube stuff off and on today
we are going to yeah people noticing
that my hair is does not actually look
the way it looked in the thumbnail for
this stream now how dare I
it's good to be back on YouTube and
we've got something a little bit
different plan for you today so I'm
actually going to be doing an interview
and the interview is going to deal with
something that I think is an important
thing which is for me my perspective
we'll talk to Eric crown in a second but
my perspective is that I think that even
if we on the Left can identify problems
with our economic system that doesn't
mean we shouldn't take advantage of the
tools that are available to us in the
personal finance world and I think Eric
agrees with that and we're going to talk
about that so we're gonna do the
interview I may then open phone lines we
will see if we get 10 new website
members I will certainly do it if we
don't I probably won't because I do have
other streams planned this week and I
think it's gonna be it's gonna be a
great time so let's see what else did I
want to address before oh okay so I've
I've drastically improved the out of the
studio streaming setup I have a better
camera my microphone setup should be
better question one am I synced like as
the aw is the audio and video synced
because that's been an ongoing issue if
people in the chat can let me know I
would appreciate that let's see yes
people mostly saying it is synced that's
good people want me to talk about yang
okay I just had a question about the
syncing but I appreciate that
nonetheless seems like it's mostly sink
to
two people sink is good okay the other
thing I've added is we will have the
super chats right over here right there
super chats will be on-screen so for
example Sam Dean has already provided a
to Australian dollar super chat which I
must much appreciate and that's great
and new members will pop up in all of
that stuff okay
so let me let's connect let's connect
with Eric crown momentarily I'm trying
to think if there was anything else I
wanted to go over we were on vacation
last week which is why I was not able to
talk about the Greenland stuff as it was
happening I was not able to talk about
the g7 like at the very beginning
although we've covered it quite a bit
but I'm back now so like we're back to
the normal schedule I know I missed a
crazy week in Trump land as April says
but it's it's good to be back and
there's a lot of stuff to talk about all
right so let's see if we can connect
here with Eric crown and then we will
see let's take a look here hey Eric hey
how you doing
good all right let's see I'm gonna pull
you up on screen here and then I think
we're gonna be we're gonna be in very
very good shape off and running there's
Eric okay so for people who don't know
Eric Eric crown is formerly a
professional equity option market maker
now a Bitcoin trader has a YouTube
channel where he does live streams
focused on market analysis and
cryptocurrency and so like is it fair to
say your politics generally speaking are
pretty left my politics um I'm pretty
much a political actually I'd like to
not get caught up in both the gangs
which I feel like as always it just kind
of dissipates you from the more tangible
things that's a trade or when we're
talking about specifically you know this
has a profession gotcha
so I mean obviously I'm sure you know my
odd I might do a left-wing show my
audience is primarily left-wing
obviously some right-wing people that
watch either because they want to see
what the opposition is doing or because
they don't like me personally or they
want to troll me
or else the case may be which is fine
but so my thing has been I mean my
background is has basically been
traditional economics albeit from a
department the University of
Massachusetts that did a lot of Marxian
stuff so that's different than a lot of
economics departments then I got an MBA
in financial planning and my view has
been I have I am aware of a lot of the
serious problems that exist structurally
in our economy and yet at the same time
I don't want to not take advantage of
tools that I can use to potentially
better society in other words if I can
understand markets and make good
investment decisions even if I think
that at some structural level we have
major problems I still think we're
better off in the net if I take
advantage of that so to speak
cryptocurrency has also been talked
about as new this libertarian anarcho
libertarian fair no leftist should be
involved with it and for me it's like
okay listen I mean it's it's risky I
don't know that I'd put more than six to
eight percent of my money in there but
if it's a tool I can use for
diversification why not that's kind of
like my approach to the system that we
have right right and you know when it
comes to look to Bitcoin I I was never
under the impression that it's that it's
either a left or right type of thing you
know Bitcoin is agnostic as far as I
understand but when it comes down to you
know profiting off of these sorts of
things or just diverse find yourself
that is a risk-averse strategy of course
which you know it's gonna speak to
anyone who wants to of course well
protect their finances on Imagine so
when you I mean help me understand a
little bit about your background and
then I want to get into some of the
things that are going on economically
you you worked in sort of just like
mainstream financial world so explain
what you even did for people who don't
even understand the field that you were
in right yeah I suppose I should tell my
story my name is Eric Brown I started
trading a long time ago my father was a
trader so I used to go down to the floor
of the Pacific Stock Exchange with him
you know ever since I was like 11 or 12
be a clerk for him each and every summer
it's where I kind of like fell in love
with the business really really
fast-paced kind of like an adult
playground down on the floor there
and well after that you know went to
college did the whole six years there
studied economics business all that good
stuff ended up leaving and then
harassing one of my family friends who I
met through my father down on the floor
who is now trading options on the floor
of new such in charka he kind of took me
under his wing taught me how to trade
options taught me how to how to analyze
markets and from there so you know spend
a lot of time with him learning his
system really really great experience
amazing person really really thank for
that and then got passed on to my next
mentor essentially another guy who had
harassed essentially and this man had
about forty years of experience and he
taught me kind of his way of doing
things he was more involved with what's
with what's called technical analysis
which very few people were actually
doing down there at the time a little
bit more of a newer thing and and that's
what really started to really open my
eyes up to the opportunities so as far
as what an options market maker does is
quite literally they are if you're
familiar with with trading options to
begin with they're quite literally
quoting both the calls and the puts
making the markets for that based upon
our own our own theoretical mark a model
of the market right so we're essentially
running some variation of usually like a
black skulls method and that's gonna
give us that's gonna populate
theoretical values for these options and
then we'll say well hey you know if if
my models telling me that this option is
worth a buck I'm willing to be a buyer
of this option for fifty cents and I'll
sell it for a buck and a half for
example right so that's that was the
whole basis of that and of course when
you're trading options you have to also
trade a spot as well just regular
straight-up stock stock underline and so
that gives you a whole all-encompassing
view of what's going on in the behind
scenes so usually when we're talking
about mark and makers on the floor of an
exchange we're usually the ones doing
the big deals with the bankers or or
independent financial institutions that
have you know extreme size and and
facilitate those attract those those
transactions essentially so how long did
you work in that space about five years
five to ten years depending upon where
you kind of counted up from but but
actual trading my own account about five
years and why did you leave I got sucked
into cryptocurrency because that raises
you way yes so in traditional markets
there's a lot of government oversight
which you know more or less is you know
there's some good
things about us some bad things about it
but it puts a lot of pressure on you
know on the individual traders as in
order to be truly truly independent you
know you really have to deal with all of
the you know all the FINRA all the SC
all the regulations which can take a lot
of time the reason one of the big
reasons why I lighted why I wanted to
come over to cryptocurrency and it's
just because you don't necessarily to
deal with that anymore there's obviously
other issues with it but I do like the
freedom so listen I mean I've made it no
secret to my audience that I believe
that much of the activity not all but
much of the activity that's taking place
on Wall Street colloquially speaking is
activity that is not economically
stimulative in the sense that a business
that is making a product which then is
purchased by people a physical product
is purchased by people and used and is
employing people in a direct sense I
don't believe that it's economically
stimulative in that way I think that
there is a lot of money being made with
money which is not in and of itself bad
I mean listen I want to make money off
interest I want to be able to save money
and and and do all of those things in
dividends and distributions what is your
sense of that perception from much of
the political left that there is non
economically stimulus sort of vulture
activity is that accurate to some degree
to no degree you know to a big degree oh
I hear this argument all the time it's
like you're an evil trader you're not
creating anything and you're just you
know moving route numbers around then
taking it out well well we don't have I
mean that that's so it going a step
further
I'm not exciting evil to the individuals
that are involved any more than I do to
a corporation but this idea that for
example a lot of the derivative stuff
that goes on that it's not helping the
economy in the same way that for example
running a farm might help the economy in
the local community or whatever example
you want to use okay yeah absolutely
mint so this at face value that sounds
like a very sound logical argument I see
I used to think the same thing until I
really got into the business the thing
is is that nothing in this world
operates in a vacuum right so if it's a
just at the most basic of basic examples
you know you are that trader who's not
necessarily creating value but have but
making value suppose you could say well
what do you do with that value
afterwards well you're gonna go spend it
right so once you start spreading it
starts getting put back into the economy
you put your you vote with your dollars
of course so you're you know rewarding
other things that you do like and that's
kind of the way that you can give back
in a more literal sense of course in
other ways like I said things don't
operate in a vacuum so there's always
gonna be some sort of downstream effects
not just like the money comes in to you
and then just you know it stays with you
forever no of course not you know money
is it's kind of worthless in and of
itself I mean just as it is it only kind
of represents what you can do with it
and so that potential is only realized
you know once you start to spread it
around and that kind of stimulates the
whole you know bring it into the whole
sphere sure I mean but I guess maybe
that's too general of a defense in the
minute and what I mean by that is you're
sort of getting at the idea that there's
a multiplier effect to money in the
economy and that money that is created
or earned or whatever initially to some
degree it is put back into the economy
and that as a multiplier effect and then
where I would go along those lines would
be okay
different money money has a different
multiplier effect depending on who earns
it for example if someone makes twenty
thousand dollars a year and you give
them a hundred bucks it's much more
likely that that hundred dollars is
actually going to be spent that if
someone makes two hundred thousand
dollars a year you give me the same
amount of money that person is more
likely to save it rather than write that
in my books me just stop you right there
that yeah okay if you are that person
you know making the higher dollar amount
of course well what's gonna happen then
again in a more literal sense just a
more obvious sense you're gonna be taxed
more of course and then houghton then
where does money go then what goes to
the government they spread it around you
know again nothing operates in a vacuum
sure although that money may well be
taxed at the capital gains rate which
could actually end up being lower but
okay we're getting kind of into the
minutia but what I wanted to we don't
and I think the audience can sort of see
were with the direction that that could
go I the next level I kind of want to
get to is once we have our understanding
of the role of the financial world and
bankers and Wall Street and all of these
tools that are available
yes disproportionately to the wealthier
we know that the lion's share of stocks
and bonds are held by the wealthy or
even when you account for
1ks and retirement accounts my view is
we are doing a disservice to ourselves
and to whatever political movement we
support doesn't matter what it is if we
don't understand and utilize these tools
to the extent that they are available to
us so this is where sometimes the left
and I will disagree where I will say I
get it the stock market is actually huge
leery distributive up rather than down
the right often complains about downward
redistribution through taxing the rich
the stock market redistributes up in a
way because the lion's share of the
dividends and the growth goes to people
who own stocks who are
disproportionately the wealthy like I
have all those critiques but to whatever
extent I can use these tools myself to
then be better equipped to do my
activism I think it's just it's not even
a responsibility it's a duty to actually
understand and do that do you I know
that you say you were a political on a
personal level but does that sort of
understanding of markets and finance as
a tool resonate with you yeah absolutely
I mean I think one of the biggest two
services that our current school system
does is they don't teach us about money
I mean financial education is you don't
get it in school so how can you expect
to be able to deal with the myriad of
financial issues that come into the
world you know coming out of there
without any sort of you know any sort of
legitimate training in it
so yeah man I'd say 100 percent use
these tools are there for you to
understand and for the people who
actually go through the trouble to
understand them they can become
extremely powerful and going back to our
former kind of conversation on the topic
you know how do you you know you know
how do you kind of give back well you do
good things with your money that's
that's how you do it yeah so there's
people in the chat for example who are
saying hey guys listen like the Amazon
is burning what the hell are you talking
about derivatives or whatever the case
may be this is where I sometimes split
with the left that I think that there's
a slice of the left that doesn't
understand the connection and what's
going on in the Amazon already relates
to money and if there were more people
with certain political views that were
participating in this system we might be
a better able to use this
in order to achieve the things that we
want it I feel like do you do you get
the sense that that connection maybe is
missing for some portion of people or
just could you know consuming what it is
that's going on 100% I mean it's it's
this weird fallacy in our society that
money has been kind of associated with
just badness or evil or if you know you
if you have money in some way you're
kind of destined as like a you know a
bad person in the sense well if you if
the people who want to make these
positive changes just made more money
well they could make those things happen
and it always comes back to that fact
right that's kind of the way that we
have our society set up for better or
worse again kind of an agnostic thing
but that is the reality as it is right
now so if you really truly want to do
something for the rain forests the best
thing to do is put yourself into a
position of power where you can actually
do something like that and of course you
know handling your finances would be a
direct way towards doing that let's talk
a little bit about what's going on now
the term recession is being thrown
around more and more everybody claims to
have their indicator that is going to
tell them whether we are or aren't in a
recession a few things that I've talked
about on my program include this is
relatively obscure actually but looking
at the number of people who are more
than 90 days behind on car payments this
is an indicator that I actually think is
an interesting one because vehicle
transportation in a lot of the country
relates very directly to the state of
one's personal finances so that's an
indicator that has been looking less and
less good you hear about the inverted
yield curve and we don't necessarily
have to go into that but that's
something but we've talked about what
question one is how do you as someone
who was working directly in this space
and still is but in a different more
independent capacity now how do you
evaluate whether we are in a recession
but maybe just as importantly are there
decisions that an individual would make
on that basis if they determine yes
we're in a recession or no we are not in
a recession that's a great question
okay so as far as discussing whether in
recession or not there's all sorts of
different indicators that you can look
at to kind of judge you know is you know
is this quite literally recession I
would say a downtrend
on you know on a monthly scale on a
yearly scale that's when we
to enter in session territory as far as
that other question and that's a
beautiful question because this is such
a talking piece right now but it always
comes back to it how are you gonna
change your personal behaviors if this
quite literally is a recession if this
is the Doomsday that a lot of people are
kind of bring it up to be which I would
argue you know yeah we probably do go
lower here but I'm not necessarily
convinced that we actually are a
recession territory just yet we can we
can perhaps get into that a bit yeah um
but realistically you know what's gonna
you know what's gonna happen is we're
gonna see interest rates go into likely
negative territories so people you know
might change their borrowing habits or
their saving habits but as far as
anything other than that the average
person you know realistic we'd probably
it's more it's more like a
conversational piece rather than like
hey I'm gonna be doing this on top of it
that's really what it comes back to you
know in my experience yeah I mean so
okay if you lose your job because of the
economic situation that's a very acute
event that takes place and then
depending on your financial situation
most people need to find another job
that that's like a very specific way in
which a quote recession could impact
someone if you're close to retirement
there may be decisions about do you want
to hold off on retirement for a few
years to not start drawing down a
retirement account for example during a
time that it is losing value that but
for a lot of people who are not about to
retire it seems as though the the
behavior may not really change that much
once you cross the border into saying we
are now in a recession right exactly
I mean that's what it comes down to it's
you have to only follow what people do
right you can't go off of what people
say and what really actually changes on
that well for the average person very
little I mean you know the job market
gets worse of course and in wages in
wages likely go down and all that good
stuff well not necessarily good stuff
but you know as far as like the personal
individual decisions I do have a little
bit of a difficult time giving like a
full-on blanket statement to it but I
would say in general yeah I would kind
of I would certainly agree with that let
me put it a different way what are the
types of things that the average person
would be thinking about in terms of
personal finance if the economy is
decidedly interest
what would the individual person think
about inside of a recession yeah in
other words what are the reasonable
things from an economic and investing
perspective would you write I mean
should people be rethinking allocation
should be thinking okay do I want to
just throw money in savings accounts
rather than continuing whatever else I'm
doing I don't know gadget okay so in a
recession you know we're gonna see the
we're gonna see the bond curl sorry the
bond yields invert right which means
that it costs more to borrow sooner
rather than later so people are gonna go
on to a more longitudinal kind of
timeframe essentially and that would
likely change those sorts of decisions
it's gonna cost more to borrow money
essentially so you know credit card fees
and whatnot they're gonna go up all
those sorts of things do you have
downwards effects absolutely but as far
as a day to day
you know those considerations likely
just likely to show up as people just
saying hey you know I want to spend less
money essentially is what they're gonna
is what it's likely didn't come down
soon yeah and that's where often you get
the vicious cycle of recession even
merely recession fears can actually
precipitate a downward cycle because
people become more conservative in their
spending because they anticipate a
recession that hurts the businesses they
would be patronizing with their money
which actually can sort of cause that
that that that recession in and of
itself I think that that's a dynamic
that is often just not even discussed
when corporate media says are we in a
recession or not the the effect that the
fear of the recession can actually have
on the economy is often not is often
understated in my view yeah yeah
absolutely I mean you know the thing is
is that they sound the alarm bells so
often on you know these these media
venues like CNBC and whatnot because it
gets people going right what's a good
headline are we going into recession is
the world about to you know fall off the
face of a cliff is it actually happening
to reality well I can show you I can
show you plenty of charts that right now
it's you know a business been arranging
for the past couple years I mean really
nothing's all changed all that much as
far as like actually you know where the
actual data is but people are being
primed with this idea that sorry that
the traditional markets let's pass a
Bitcoin but the traditional marks are
gonna go you know flatline essentially
and you should be panicking right now
well of course as you said and again oh
it always comes back to this fact
nothing operates in a vacuum people are
gonna be making decisions based upon
that and it kind of precipitates these
sorts of things and it becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy in a way so
with that said because I actually kind
of have a theory now that because people
are making these decisions a little bit
prematurely because they're being you
know emotionally essentially like
emotionally kind of dragged across the
field with it it almost allows the game
to go on a little bit longer so right
now we're we're kind of that in the
general markets is we're kind of like at
the we're getting we're getting pretty
damn close to the top of the top I'd
imagine yes the recession is likely
coming yes there is likely gonna be some
massive downside but even listen to the
news they've been telling you that for
the last like two or three years they've
been shoving in your face every damn
time the thing is is that the Fed and
because we have Trump in office right
now there's a lot of extra games that
can be played it's no secret that trumps
whole calling card is a stock market
again this is not a statement from my
own from my own sense but Trump he runs
off the stock market he's I was there
when he got elected that the thing just
went up and it didn't stop going up I'll
put it that way
and it's been you know more or less
pretty damn good ever since then you
know just just for like the average
sector so with that said we know we can
we can kind of deduce that Trump is
likely going to do everything in his
power to keep the stock market rising
how does he do that well he boys the Fed
right that while I was going to say that
there's been this pattern of a good
stock market month is thanks to Trump a
bad stock market month is because the
Fed isn't doing what Trump wants it's
it's it's get take credit for the winds
and blame somebody else for the losses
essentially right and that's in yeah
it's great isn't it scary though that
that's you know that's our well I mean
if we can get people to believe it it's
an extremely great place to be as the
president of the United States right
it's a no-lose situation you know it's
kind of like the the bank's socializing
the losses right yeah so yeah so the way
that Trump will do it is you know he
either boys left that into doing what he
wants which is just lower interest rates
we see a few countries like like like
mainstream first first world countries
going into negative rates I think Japan
Japan's there I think Germany is is just
went there I believe and the United
States is almost pretty much destined to
follow so we're gonna go to negative
rates so the Fed has more bullets in
their chamber but if they were to fight
Trump and this is what he kind of
revealed on his head you know on his
hand you know I think in the last few
weeks is that if he doesn't get his way
what does he do he does tariffs so he
get he gets it either which way so we
can probably deduce that he's gonna be
doing something like this in order to
just in order just prop up the stock
market at least until the election not
imagine and then after that you know the
Fed can keep on printing some free money
which of course that creates a whole lot
of other problems but I'm sure that you
that you're probably familiar with this
being an economics person yourself that
there's this great there's this great
theory going out right now this great
macroeconomic theory called modern
economic theory and it essentially says
it essentially said something like this
we can print as much money as possible
oh you mean modern monetary Theory
modern monetary theory yes you can print
as much money as possible and it's no
problem except for something called
inflation just except for something
called inflation right that is a
legitimate problem of course you know so
yeah well what I think it's maybe more I
mean okay so let that's that's a very
umbrella overview of mmm tea I encourage
people in the audience to check out my
interview with stephanie kelton about mm
tea where we go into into quite a bit of
detail and Pavlina turn ava also who's
really good on this issue I mean I think
a more nuanced understanding of it would
be merely printing money if it's for
economically stimulative purposes is not
going to trigger the inflation spiral
that like a supply-side debt hawk claims
that it will I don't think I've ever
heard any money mmm tea person say it
literally does not matter how much money
the Fed prints and what it's used for I
think that the more may be more precise
would be if we think about okay if
everybody had health care fewer people
would be sick meaning more people would
work and crime would go down that would
be an okay reason to print money and it
wouldn't cause a
an endless inflationary death spiral on
the other hand if we just print money to
give it to the point one percent who are
mostly going to save it that may not be
such a good reason I mean I think that's
my understanding of how M and M MT
scholars right right you can you can
certainly say that and that would be a
more nuanced understanding absolutely
the point that I'm making though in it
always comes back to that fact man
nothing operates in a vacuum sure if we
start doing that it's a slippery slope
it goes it goes into some very bizarre
places I would be very hard-pressed to
say that just printing money for it just
for the purpose of printing money even
in those sorts of situations it you mean
I think that's the point it's something
that we don't worry it's not for the
purpose of merely printing the money
it's hey here is the here are the
economic losses from for example not
people going bankrupt from not having
health care missing work from not having
health care you can kind of find the
economic value of all those all those
losses but hold on you can say no but
hold on me just finished it
you could calculate that imagine that
that is you know a trillion dollars that
doesn't matter what the numbers you
could then say all right if the Fed can
get everybody health care by printing
half of that amount even accounting for
the inflationary effect we're still
better off in the net I think that's the
calculation that God okay okay that I
can understand yes but in a base sense
in a base sense if let's say let's say
there's a hundred thousand dollars in
existence right now and you and you have
10 of those and then I say David we're
gonna do this mmm tea I'm gonna start
printing 50 thousand I'm gonna start
printing 50 thousand every day because
we need to you know we need more health
care what happens to your dollar even
though that's that's a good thing net it
will be good it will be beneficial but
what happens to you personally your
dollar yeah I think that that's just the
wrong question in the sense that it's a
it's a sort of myopic way we don't think
about so okay let me back up
imagine that we do Medicare for all
right there's a ton of people that are
gonna lose their jobs as a result in
other words you eliminate the need for a
lot of medical you know insurance fraud
investigators you eliminate the need for
a lot of medical
coders that work for the insurance
company and medical coders that work for
the hospital like jobs will be lost but
there is no decision that can be made in
a country of 340 million people that
will not have some costs the question is
at the breakwater level I think you're
missing my point
it's okay it's quite literally just the
fact that it devalues your dollar your
person your purchasing power has gone
down just by that metric anytime that
they print more money that's always
gonna be a fact correct uh well I I mean
so again you going back to what your
knowledge is nothing happens in a vacuum
if there's more money in circulation and
you have the same amount your your
purchasing power will go down if
literals
if you if you consider no other factors
and do the thought experiment merely in
a vacuum you are correct
but I would I would quote you from five
minutes ago or ten minutes ago nothing
yet none of this stuff is happening in a
vacuum but in any case we may be getting
all cried with this yeah but it's a good
conversation anyways I mean that's yes
we could certainly talk about something
like that but that's certainly not my
forte when we're getting into like
actual market analysis right so let's go
back to that a little bit because so
there so the next thing I kind of wanted
to get into was when it comes to so okay
I'll give an example when in 2012 Mitt
Romney was running against Barack
Obama's re-election at the time both
were making promises about what they
would do as stewards of the economy my
view at the time was were probably in
for for pretty good years no matter
which of these two guys wins in other
words all the indicators at the time
were things are quite stable
unemployment is decreasing companies are
making money etc there may be an
inflection point well we're at a very we
were at a very unique point in the
market at that point we were literally
coming out of the you know out of the
2008 area right right yes so so it's you
know it's easy to go up when you're
coming from from from a very massive
economic catastrophe essentially no
question about it so and and in the end
Barack Obama got reelected and the
economy did well if Mitt Romney had
gotten elected quite frankly the Econo
probably would have done similarly well
although there would have been some
decisions made that that could have
altered that maybe things related to tax
cuts okay when you look now at 2020 is
your view that the four years that
follow will be sort of insulated from
who wins in 2020 or do you actually
think that Trump reelection versus
somebody else will create a serious
inflection point for the four years that
follow so that that's a really good
question um the thing is is that it
doesn't just operate on a year-to-year
basis right what's being done now has
implications go in all words and
forwards and because we're at such a
critical point in just the overall
sphere just the overall health of the
economy we really don't have too many
more bullets to you know to kind of
force into the economy right now so no
matter who goes on for the next four
years
whether it's Trump whether it's you know
insert Democrat name here you know what
imagine that it's gonna be a little bit
of the more of the same and then
probably really realists way you know I
do you think that it's kind of like a
ticking time bomb on this you know on
this market within the next three to
three to five years I would imagine we
probably do play out that actual
downside and legitimately do you know
you legitimately do you haven't have a
real recession no matter who's in charge
there's just no there's just very little
place for you know for the Fed to work
around this right now I mean they can
like I said that they they can lower
they can lower interest rates a little
bit more they can print more money
that's that's all well and good up until
a point right where it becomes whether
it becomes diminishing returns and they
start actually doing a lot more harm
than good
and that's and that's when real problems
what she happened so you know whoever
whoever kind of enhanced that and that
that economy they're gonna get blamed
for it of course whether it's Trump
whether it's Democrat doesn't matter who
it is they're gonna be they're gonna be
dealt a pretty bad hand essentially I
mean I think that I basically am in
agreement with you I think that a lot so
every day we're a day closer to the next
recession doesn't I mean I know when it
is and we're notably terrible I'd
actually saying when it's going to be
there were people in 2014 saying it'll
definitely be in 2016 you know I mean
whatever we know that we're so bad what
we do know is every day we're it were a
day closer for me at this point the big
thing with Trump and this is getting
political
is that I think that a lot of the impact
on the market is going to be number one
related to the trade war and that is
that's less psychological but it's more
just real and then number two it's going
to be confidence quite frankly because
when when Donald Trump does the
cartoonish stuff that I think everybody
agrees he does there are people who
defend it and people who don't defend it
when he does the cartoonish stuff I
think it's scaring people around the
world and it is rattling markets and I
think that that is more I'm basically
agreeing with you that on policy there
is a sort of more or less predetermined
path in a lot of ways that is set by
factors outside right White House I
think there's a lot of psychological
stuff that will be impacted by whether
he's reelected or not yeah it'll be able
to be a lot of psychology of course but
just in the general of day-to-day right
now this is a very unique market that we
have because one tweet can really really
rock things yeah I have never
experienced anything like this before
this is one of the reasons we'll
actually left traditional market just
because my edge is with technical
analysis not with analyzing political
spheres and this is a highly political
market right now it's in fact the in
fact I can't recall a time before this
that it was ever like this you know
doing doing studies all the way back to
the 1950s essentially this is completely
unique and one of those things where you
know Trump knows what he's doing he
knows how to play the game when it comes
to the stock market you know love him or
hate him he'd you know he he does have
kind of a method to his madness with the
way that he run things up so yes you
know I would agree with what you're
saying in there and even take it a step
further and saying that you know
regardless of whether Trump is elected
or not the damage that we're doing right
now is it it's there's really no way to
kind of undo it without playing out a
little bit of a recession you know yes
it is gonna happen let me okay so I want
to talk a little bit about Bitcoin and
then I want to ask you a couple of other
specifics sort of personal finance
questions and then for people who are
watching I have no clue how many people
have been signing up but if we do get 10
new members on the website when we're
done talking with Eric I will open up
the phone lines if people if people are
interested in that and if they're not
that that's okay - okay so Bitcoin I got
into Bitcoin not like Earl
early but certainly years ago and okay
so I wrote it up and then it's kind of
back down and I sold bits and pieces of
it and I still holds them whatever okay
do I think that bitcoin is the future I
don't know do I think that some version
some crypto is likely to achieve big
enough adoption that it will become kind
of like the transactional currency that
some dream of I think that that's
possible but for me the biggest barriers
right now are one price volatility
number two adoption and number three the
sort of infrastructure that leads to
often on transaction delay issues
question one do you think that those
three are the biggest issues or are
there others or are those not issues and
question two sort of like how are you
big picturing crypto right now right
okay so as far as just answer the
question straight up um you know could
it be another cryptocurrency
yeah I mean you always want to keep an
open mind with that but I'd say one of
the biggest one of the biggest things
for Bitcoin right now that it has going
for it is it's been ten years without
any you know real problems it's it's
been working so you know when we're
talking about programming a crypto
currency that's gonna be holding you
know hundreds of the only or hundreds of
billions trillions of dollars you you
have to make sure that it's secure you
have to make sure that the protocol
works you need to it needs to be sick it
needs to be good right so we have we so
it's the only one that has that that big
of a history to go online with it as far
as a question about the infrastructure
being built we're seeing that happen
right now CME's have office are CMI's
which is the Chicago Mercantile Exchange
which is a major US Exchange offers
Bitcoin futures as of December 2017 and
we actually are working on getting
what's called backs now coming up in
next month I'm looking at the date right
now it's it's literally about one month
away from now and that's also gonna be
on major US markets ETFs are being
talked about and postulated they've been
they've been thrown into the you know
for the SEC to deal with over the past
year plenty of them so it's just kind of
a matter of time we see the
infrastructure being built up which
tells me that the financial industry is
gearing up for something like this
they're not wasting their time you know
going through all the rigged more
roll which believe me there is a ton of
rigmarole with getting any of these
assets approved for just trading in
general and and that tells me that there
is serious belief in this not only that
but we see a lot of major major major
banks and whatnot starting to you know
have cryptocurrency deaths I mean you
even hear about JP Morgan having their
own internal cryptocurrency a little bit
of a different thing of course but this
this whole sphere is is it's actually
pretty right with the with the financial
industry just because we're ever there
are so many quad firms in this right now
and they're growing day by day they're
there a significant interest right now
and it's growing is what we've seen over
the past you know the past year or so I
mean really of the Pat you know every
Chembur year grows of course but really
been picking up exponentially in the
last couple years so I mean okay I guess
Bitcoin kind of works I guess when so at
the point eighteen months ago when the
price was fluctuating wildly at the same
time that transactions were taking 24
hours and costing 20 bucks it's like yes
technically worked but like is that
really as designed
well hold on I'd have to correct you on
that I'm not sure that that's true that
it takes 24 hours to do a transaction it
takes about 10 minutes which is still
kind of long you know if you okay but
there let me let me correct let me
correct so the takes 10 minutes to if
I'm using the right terminology process
the block but there was a point at which
it was taking 24 hours to get to the
block you might have been waiting for is
that more accurate yes so about two
years ago during 2017 Bitcoin went
parabolic from about what was it like a
thousand bucks to twenty Baalak I like
that right and during that time the
instruction for Bitcoin was quite was
quite young and so yes when a lot of a
lot of people at once we're like trying
to send things through and it was that
everything would kind of build up in the
you know in the miners pool essentially
I mean I'm not using the right
terminology but this but just to you
know in layman's turn I suppose so they
would have a lot of things to process
right so yes it would take a long time
at that time but that improves over time
there's been significant improvements
with the brick with the Bitcoin protocol
we have segments now we yet you know and
there's more things along the way which
helps speed those transactions up got it
okay fair enough yeah so okay good so
from from a sort of forward-looking
perspective my view is
the Bitcoin I have the etherium I have
the litecoin etc I consider it extremely
speculative I consider it sort of you
know so like my main thing is I invest
in the lowest fee mutual funds possible
betterment and Vanguard you're talking
about five to ten basis points then I
pick some individual stocks but
relatively few because I just don't
think I'm that good at it unless I
really devote a lot of time to it so
like I've been in Tesla for a really
long time as people in my headings know
and sometimes buried or whatever okay
and then it's like I've got money just
in like a high-yield savings account and
then I've got some crypto but I consider
it it could disappear overnight is that
the approach I should have with that
money or are we moving away from it
being at that precarious so we need to
really separate Bitcoin from what we
call locally referred to as [ __ ] coins
okay and the majority of anything not
named Bitcoin is mostly worthless mostly
garbage has zero real purpose has zero
intentions to ever complete what they
set out to do there's probably gonna be
some extremely successful all coins
absolutely no doubt about it it would be
naive to you know to say not it also
could be not it also be naive to say
that perhaps something else overtakes
Bitcoin you know we don't know yet
if you're still extremely young of
course but at the end of the day Bitcoin
seems to be the it does seem to be a
little bit of a winner-take-all scenario
with the whole store of value argument
which I believe is what bitcoins going
for first and foremost so so in other
words so you're saying that if people
people need to understand what it is
that Bitcoin even purports to be if it's
something that they're going to be
involved in right exactly you know a lot
of people when people talked about
crypto currencies or anything like that
they don't talk about hey man I bought
XYZ chained coin because I'm gonna use
this for my next project no right you're
talking about it because they're saying
hey I think this one's gonna go up and
I'm gonna sell it higher that games
gonna go on for a while because that's
the sexy part about Bitcoin right now
the gains are the potential gains also
potential losses are astronomically high
I and so when we're when you're going
back and making that relation with
traditional markets yes it makes sense
to just do a little bit in some in
something speculative like
cryptocurrency which I do think gains
more and more traction over time but
even then with even just putting in a
little bit it still it helps diversify
you and then of course the gains on
Bitcoin they come in in they come in X's
whereas in traditional markets they come
in you know like a few percentage points
right sure so that's the whole that's
the whole magic of Bitcoin right now and
what I think is mostly alluring to
people as as people look at this as you
know going to 50 thousand a hundred
thousand you know these these crazy
moonboy numbers which may be possible I
mean I think it's Act I think you could
actually come up with some pretty damn
good arguments for it I'm not sure about
the John mccafé 1 million dollar
prediction I don't know about that one
no but I do think that there is upside
potential and and so for the average
investor it would make sense to just put
some into Bitcoin just because it's a
hedge it's it can be viewed in some ways
as a hedge against your stock portfolio
I could also go into that and really
destroy that argument too I don't I'm
not necessarily convinced that it's it's
so much of a hedge just like I don't
think gold is a hedge or silver as a
hedge or any of them right well that's
so I mean that gets us to just zoom out
a little bit which is ok if for the
average person right I mean you hear
about there's so much money going into
pumping gold gold gold and also
collectible coins scams which I'm glad
to talk about but I don't think we even
really need to but gold bullion as a
store of value as a hedge against
markets there are people who talk about
you know that the high-yield savings
account when it's available at 2.5%
which as the federal fund rates funds
rate now drops most of those 2.5
accounts are dropping to 2 I just got an
email today from one of my banks about
that that's where you want to be or
Bitcoin or whatever for the average
person I mean what should there you know
I've been reading about no more than 10
percent in precious metals no more than
six to eight percent in cryptocurrency
and even that may be too much for some
people do these numbers sound about
right to you do they sound crazy you
know the thing is is that if we're being
completely if I'm just gonna straight
just straight shoot you right now
there's no hedge against a real market
downturn a full
right there's no hedge yeah what
happened during 2008 for gold went down
35% just like all the other sacks of
[ __ ] they all went down there is no real
hedge that's why I really really really
really really caution against all of
these doom and gloom errs who are almost
cheering on a recession you have to
understand this is gonna have caused a
lot of pain economically speaking people
are gonna be really really hurt as far
there's also people by their way there's
people there's people in my demographic
right Millennials who basically came out
of college at the end of the recession
and have have worked for the last you
know more than 10 years in basically a
good economy and I'm gonna mark even one
event I think hey you know what I've
done the tests for risk tolerance
if I lose 30% from what 40% from what
I've built up over the last ten years
I'm gonna stay the road and just keep
doing my thing I don't even know that I
believe that like I feel like I'm kind
of being myself with that because I'm
part of a demographic that has only seen
you know eight 10 percent downturn and
then things recover and the dividends
are steady throughout I think a lot of
people are gonna be crushed
psychologically by it crushed
psychologically and also financially I
mean and I said it's it's if you are the
kind of person who's cheering on this
sort of thing on it you have to really
understand what this means
this means like pain
this means real real pain we do we have
not experienced pain in a long time
the last real I mean of course 2008 was
pretty bad but that was it was
relatively fast you know it's about a
year and a half of straight down then
popped back up
v-bottom back within the next year and
then shot up shot up to heaven
essentially you know the the last time
that we really had a legitimate crash
sustained crash I suppose I suppose was
like 87 or 88 which I was not trading
during that time of course but yeah so
so people quickly forget right the
markets been more or less extremely
rewarding and I don't and during 2008
you know a lot of people didn't even
feel all that much pain I've showed her
from saying that because I know that I'm
gonna really piss some people off yes I
totally understand that a lot of people
did but it was almost by four
the way that it was kind of set off you
know some there's certainly bubbles
where this did not really affect all
that much going back to our former
conversation of you know how how
rewarding some people with money doesn't
really change all that much for the
general economy but this next one would
likely would likely be I mean the thing
is is that this next one's gonna be
likely worse than anything that we've
seen you know in the last twenty thirty
years you know I I don't even really
know what to mark it off of but I would
say that you know it's we're talking
about a point where the marks can get so
bad that you know it's it's no fun to be
the one rich person where you walk
outside and then everyone's you know
begging for money or something like that
that's yeah it might be worse to be the
person begging for money though but yeah
I mean one of those one of the sayings
that I believe a lot in is a rising tide
lifts all ships so you know going back
to that I people who are cheering
someone like this on I think are
massively misguided if they did some if
in some way the market down turning
benefits you know your Gold position or
your or your beautiful hedge there
hasn't there isn't really any real hedge
you know it's it's almost like a fallacy
that we tell ourselves in fact the
funnily enough you know what the best
hedge that I've actually found with with
with data the best hedge in this is
gonna sound weird but the best hedge
thus far is actually soybeans you know
legitimate commodities you know you know
buying more buy more gold buying more
silver at the end of the day meant if
things really do crash down especially
anything anything like 2008 which I
think it would be I think it would be
worse you know we're gonna see that go
down just the same thing and in
realistically the best you know the best
hedge against it is is likely going to
be real commodities like real actual
consumable things that that people need
that people want that people use now
explain this because so my knowledge of
commodities is extremely limited but
over time doesn't technology over time
reduce the market value of commodities
in that they become easier to produce I
mean so maybe what yeah I don't know if
that's true but maybe you mean that in
the short term during
taking the recession that that doesn't
happen well to go back on to that you
know technology making commodities
easier to essentially make I suppose yes
but even taking it one step further I
mean let's just look a little bit into
the future where are we going you know I
mean just in the more in the not so
distant future we could talk about three
3d printing right so now your cost of
production for something like you know
even like gold I mean they're gonna be
able to make that at some point in time
or maybe we go off to a different you
know you know maybe we start exploring
different planets and we find a planet
made of gold you know I'm we're in a
universe of infinite possibilities of
course so that that show a little bit
less foresight you know if you're
looking into the future those sorts of
things yes they likely do lose their
value but at the same point in time you
know what's what's like the most what's
like the most valuable resource right
now it means water essentially and what
is it cost it's pretty much free in a
sense I mean that's kind of the way that
we think about it well I thanks to a lot
of big beverage companies it's no longer
I mean they're they're taking free water
and then selling it which is a crazy I
mean it's it's insane welcome what
they're doing they're really selling the
bottle yeah yeah listen the last thing I
wanted to touch on along these lines is
from your your time as a trader what did
you learn about psychology where it
comes to market psychology investing
psychology that would be interesting and
maybe applicable to everyday life all of
it what I can say about this is actually
something that I'm quite passionate
about so psychology with with with
regards to being a trader to be a
successful trader is to is to have to
learn a lot about yourself and what it
really comes down to is psychologically
speaking you're gonna have to kind of
theory fate face your own demons in a
sense because we are as humans are
emotional beings of course we're run by
emotions we're governed by emotions the
problem is when you want to be a trader
you need to be asking the logical side
side of your brain which is of course
divorced from your emotional side and
actually in fact when you're in those
emotional states you are quite literally
blocked off from from accessing your you
know your logical states so in order to
become a trader psychologically speaking
you need to have you need to figure out
a way in order to
facilitate getting back into that
logical state how does that look for
most people well I can only speak for
myself I suppose and what I found for
myself is you know do taking essentially
the holistic approach you know going and
working out eating uh you didn't know a
balanced diet for myself that means most
mostly meat you know going to sauna for
myself found helps a lot meditation
reading books those sorts of things have
really helped me understand my own
thought processes and kind of calm down
in the moment because when price actions
screaming against you and in and you're
watching yourself you know potentially
take a massive paper loss or perhaps in
a good scenario you're watching yourself
have a massive paper gained but you're
blocked off for making those logical
decisions perhaps you know a lot of the
time you're gonna make the wrong
decision in the moment you know of
course you know a lot of the time what
people don't realize is the is the
positive states are just as bad as or
sorry just as destructive as the
negative states a lot of people will see
themselves make a ton of money like they
did in 2017 especially with
cryptocurrencies Bitcoin things were
just going to the damn moon they coined
up to 20,000 but what happens people get
caught in that emotional state they get
too exuberant they get too irrational
and they forget to sell and they forget
to sell but of course if you come back
to it you know you know a week later a
year later whatever it whatever time
that it takes and look at it just just
as the facts as it is you're like man
this has gone up about 10x I think it's
time to take a little bit of profit
that's not being so greedy you know so
those sorts of things with understanding
your own psychology are so damn
important but really fighting your own
inner demons with usually fear it
usually comes in some way down to fear
with managing your positions usually
most people find this going against them
not the positive aspect although I'm
sure that there's a lot of people from
2017 all you know still remembering that
as well and then of course more recently
2018 the bear market and
cryptocurrencies as well you know a
little bit more a little bit more
proximal I suppose you know you go
through those emotional states and the
conditioning of those emotions can at
first destroy you right a lot of the
times we have to go through these sorts
of situations so that we can get that
feel those emotions and then get the
emotional leverage to make a change but
it's not before you actually feel that
feel those very very bad emotions before
you can actually open yourself up and
make that change as a person so as a
trader you kind of learn
how to grow again and again and again as
the market throws new and new and
dynamic things against you as you have
to reinterpret these situations and then
usually you know once you kind of create
your own little toolbox with how to you
know with how to learn from it you know
you feel those motions you can identify
it you say hey this is this is once
again that fear emotion that foam
emotion that whatever emotion it's time
to step back and that's the key step
back and then analyze go and look in and
do a little bit more of a you know self
reflection on it
I think journaling helps a ton with kind
of just seeing your own thought
processes so to really just be that
watcher and and kind of look at things
from a distance is really what training
has taught me and I've found for a lot
of other people as well you know trading
really helps keep things in perspective
and that obviously flows on it over into
any part of your life I mean you know
you know these sorts of emotional states
you'll encounter in just about anything
I'm sure you know I'm sure you know with
your YouTube channel like what happens
when you know when you first started
what happens when someone sends you a
bunch of bad comments they say David I
hate you if your hair is stupid and
right and I've hoped a lot of people say
my hair is stupid you must have seen
some of those look like look how you
came out of a damn cave you know it's
it's it's one of those things though but
at first it probably really rocked you
emotionally or at least I'd imagine you
know your your person we're all people
it doesn't feel good to hear those sorts
of things but after that you're you know
at you know after you know after a
little bit you can you you kind of
realize that this is you know just
another person on the internet and maybe
they're having a bad day maybe they're
not looking at things completely logical
and you should actually be in some ways
understanding of them you know and in
and that's really where it always comes
back to you so you learned that sort of
cool you you you get that sort of
skillset that tool said I suppose you
could say with just being able to
analyze problems from a distance look at
it logically and not get caught up in
your emission your initial emotional
response that's the key thing not
getting caught up in that initial
emotional response which we're always
gonna feel I always feel it you know or
well I guess feel a little bit less now
but I still you have the feeling it when
I'm getting into potentially a uh you
know a trades going against me but I can
step back and recognize it now that's
the whole difference and that's what you
learn from something like this and you
can apply to just about anything in your
life
well most of what you said makes a lot
of sense other than what do you mean by
a balanced diet is mostly meat that's it
that's I've never heard that before yeah
so you know I've I've done a lot of work
with my own diet I've ate in some ways a
mostly vegetarian diet I've made you
know a paleo diet and then I started
just eating mostly meat actually which
for me seems to seem to do the best
actually weirdly enough you know it's
it's one of those things you wouldn't
have thought it I would have never
thought that I would have turn into some
sort of weird meat-eating carnivores
it's what they're talking but there is
some would be said about that man
i I've certainly noticed that when you
eat carbs you go through you you
actually become a little bit more
emotional in a sense or at least I've
noticed I'm not sure that this is
evidence-based let me ask you this you
didn't once in the midst of the
meat-eating accidentally have a
tablespoon of apple cider vinegar and
get knocked out for a month right that's
ever happened you know I used to do that
man
I used to do that when I first started
but now no not at all man not at all
that's good that's that's a good thing
to hear well listen I I hope that this
is this has been very different for my
audience I hope people will have enjoyed
the live stream and we're gonna archive
this and my interview with Eric crown is
going to be available on demand for you
Eric is a former professional equity
option market trader he has a YouTube
channel where he live streams which you
should check out he does market analysis
crypto stuff really appreciate you
joining me Eric I mean this has been
it's been different and informative we
agreed about some things we disagreed
about some things and I think it's been
really great yeah absolutely man it was
a pleasure meeting you David Pakman
you're a damn legend and thanks for
having me on man really appreciate that
into all the people out there hey if you
want to come on over and check out the
live streams understand this is a very
crass life it's very fun at times too of
course but mostly you know it's it's
mostly business talking about Bitcoin
talking about general markets analyzing
the whole thing and coming up with plans
and talking a lot about psychology as
well so if you enjoy those sorts of
conversations definitely feel free to
come on in and love to meet you outbound
question recommend a couple books for
our audience please oh man okay not
necessarily related to what you do just
like I feel like people
books is also interesting so okay so I
would say the first and foremost book
that I that I think has changed my life
incredibly important would definitely be
the power of now by Eckhart Tolle Wow
life-changing and 100% translate
directly into trading I mean that's
basically that whole spiel that I that I
kind of laid out earlier that would be
you know directly gained from that book
absolutely the second book would be
psycho cybernetics by maxwell or
something Maxwell Malcolm max um
something like that another amazing book
more about just the way that you kind of
view reality and you view yourself and
how that kind of prepares kind of
changed their whole worldview I thought
that that was extremely helpful as well
and I suppose one that is a little bit
more focused on trading but it's it's
the psychology of trading not like
trading strategies but just the
psychology of trading which I thought
was phenomenal was trading in the zone
by Mark Douglas amazing book again kind
of goes back to those Eckhart Tolle
concepts I suppose you could say and
really really really really helped me
not just with trading but also just
understanding my own thought processes
I've never read the second I'd have
never heard of the second - I've read
the power Wow by Eckhart Tolle and he
says some interesting things but the
more I read about him he seems pretty
kooky but I don't know but in any case
it's an interesting book I've read it
it's it's one of those things man you
know you take from it what you want to
take and you can kind of just regard the
rest like yeah yeah there's some but
exactly exactly right all right Eric
crown thank you so much we'll do it
again and I really appreciate your time
thank you very much David it's pleasure
being here all right I'm gonna keep
streaming so I will disconnect with you
Eric but we'll follow up later thank you
so much and we've got what else so I'm
still here for people who want to do
other stuff I'll stream for a little
while longer so I had this let me see
here let me pull up how can I actually
do this let me see we had okay let me
see I had a thing up saying that if we
got 10 new members I would open up the
phone lines this could be we might have
zero it could be really really
embarrassed
okay no we actually do overview okay so
Kristi sill mess is a new member and
Steven Jimenez is a new member and Sara
bumpass is a new member so let me let's
see I need to figure out the right way
to do this okay so I can update the new
member chat here members where is this
right so we've got I think I'm doing all
the stuff in real time okay we have
three new website members if we get
seven more there's a discount code right
there I'll open up the phone lines and
we can hear from people at six one seven
eight three zero 47:54 people asking me
am i no longer streaming on Twitch
I am streaming on Twitch I am going to
keep doing stuff at twitch TV slash
David Pakman and I will be doing stuff
on YouTube as well and I'm just gonna
alternate and that's basically that let
me deal with some of the super chats
that are here Matthew Dominguez David
what's your favorite type of tacos
hashtag yang gang um my favorite type of
it really depends on the mood I mean a
good fish taco is great how can you do
better than a good fish taco but I often
just like a grilled grilled chicken taco
is good if the chicken is properly
grilled and nicely nicely nicely grilled
skit foot what do I know Sara B is a new
YouTube member watcher is a new YouTube
member riege e25 for Waco says thank you
David for all your hard work I
appreciate that
Angie 978 says it's all I've got thanks
for your work appreciate that
Zee Feld's says left right or center I'm
gay for ta I have no idea what that
means
long live the corn Ramon Rodriguez says
hi David love what you do Siegfried
Richter with a twenty dollar super chat
the hi super chat for the evening which
I appreciate and Beth Houghton huffed
often Houghton with a five dollar super
chat and I
already mentioned Sam Dean there so I
really appreciate that thank you very
much okay let me briefly take I need to
figure out the right this is not
actually the right streaming setup here
let me take the Super chats off the
screen momentarily just so I can do a
couple of other things here off screen
okay what else did I have on my list
here oh okay and Nicole Smith is also a
new david pakman show member so let me
update that we now have four of ten if
we get ten the number is up there if we
get to ten website members I will open
up the phone lines and people can call
in if people want to talk to me let me
see what's happening in the regular chat
here a lot of stuff about Andrew yang
people talking about vegan diets and
other stuff some people are leaving some
people are coming in some people are
happy now that the interview is over
some people are sad that the interview
is over yeah I mean that was very
different for sure and hopefully it was
it was relevant relevant to people's
interests so to speak okay so let me ask
are people generally interested in me
taking phone calls or is that not
interesting I know we're only 40 percent
of the way there as far as the members
go but do people want to call in today
or do you want me to do other stuff
because they do have other things I can
do and in fact this Andino thing I sort
of wanted to talk about
will I be alternating between twitch and
YouTube yeah yeah I mean I will not one
person not interested in phone calls and
about 20 people interested in phone
calls a lot of people interested in
phone calls people saying David play
Minecraft yeah I don't I just don't know
how so it's not something I'd be able to
do so listen let me briefly so as you
can see this is the david pakman show
subreddit which if you are not a
subscriber to you really should be
reddit the the URL is very long but you
could just go to david pakman.com slash
reddit one of the things that i want to
talk about maybe on tomorrow's program
is about and ii know let's take a look
at this article and ii know is a guy who
i had never heard of him before he was
attacked at some rally by people
ostensibly associated with an Tifa i
guess and immediately there were i mean
of course it's horrible that he was
attacked and i'm against violence period
and that's it i mean it's just you don't
even need to say anything else but there
were sort of some weird things like he
was talking about how he was attacked
with concrete what looked like milk
milkshakes but they were concrete and
you know that could be but I guess
damaging or something I don't know and
it seemed that there wasn't really
evidence of that and then he got a bunch
of interviews and a bunch of media
attention he was on Joe Rogan he was
interviewed by Dave Rubin and so I think
he was even on Fox News and then there
started to be sort of some weird stuff
like something seems weird I mean one
thing which is kind of silly but but
it's also odd is that he talks with sort
of a British accent and then it was like
well where did you get the British
accent and at one point he said that at
some for some period of time like his
dad is British or part British or
something I don't even know but it was
sort of like why do you talk with a
British accent maybe there's something a
little just off about this guy then and
I'm going from memory here then it was
reported he reported that he witnessed
and Tifa people hitting someone with a
hammer but in reality it was like the
the right-wingers who actually first
introduced a hammer into a situation and
then when he was called out for having
incorrectly reported that it was the
left wingers hammering people he said
well no the people using the hammers
were the right wingers but they were
doing it in self-defense so it was like
but you reported the opposite to begin
with it didn't really make sense it was
weird and then now
there has been an even bigger thing
which I'm trying to read about now where
he was witnessed with a far-right group
planning violence but never reported it
and now he has left
Willett and I mean my view is that this
guy is just the worst I mean nobody I'm
against violence period I'm just against
violence that's it and the the when he
was attacked I denounced it and I was
against it of course but this guy really
seems to be totally totally totally
toxic and if I have time tomorrow I mean
like this isn't the most important thing
but if I have time tomorrow I absolutely
am going to be talking about it okay let
me see here we've got a couple of other
super chats coming in Lucy with a gun
says now into the presidency would Ted
Cruz be better better than Trump I don't
I mean who knows I don't know it's so
hard to say at this point because
nothing happens in a vacuum if we
replace Trump now with Cruz would we be
better off or if Cruz had been the
president from the beginning I don't
know Justin Quadron Quran says hi David
are you familiar with the work of Robert
Evans he put out a book about the
history of white fascism called the war
on everyone I'm familiar with them but I
am not familiar with that book Matthew
Dominguez would you ever talk to the
guys from problem-solver politics they
learn libertarian they Lee leaning I
guess you mean libertarian but are huge
yang supporters
I feel it'd be an interesting
conversation I don't know them I'm open
to it if I learn more about it Stephen
Robbins who also I believe goes by the
name of Ronald Reagan on other programs
a programs I could not possibly name is
asking if we're doing calls I don't know
if we're doing calls quite frankly
because we have let me see here we still
have only four new website members and I
said if we get ten I'll do calls if
you're new here let me explain to you
website membership and maybe this will
get us six more and then maybe I will
finally speak to Ronald Reagan who is I
don't has never successfully called into
my show
as far as I know membership is the
number one funding source for my program
so it's like we've got YouTube revenue
and it goes up and down like a really
bad looking EKG there's YouTube super
chat but YouTube takes 30% of that there
is patreon but patreon takes like five
to nine percent of that so membership we
control the entire process we control
our website all we pay is 2.9%
to the payment processing company and we
keep ninety seven point one percent of
every payment okay I'll show you what
the website looks like it's really quick
to do this all you do is you go to my
website you pick a yearly or a monthly
membership you hit the sign up button
then we have coupon codes available if I
type in the coupon code for example this
is 20 20 the six dollar membership
becomes just three dollars and sixty
cents okay if I do a yearly membership
and I hit sign up the same coupon code
works I'll even give you a special
secret coupon code if you type half 19
that's 50% off 30 bucks for the entire
year we do you know 10 to 12 hours a
week of programming between the
broadcast show and live streams and live
calls and all of this different stuff
it's really cheap we keep ninety seven
point one percent of every payment and
that's why we talk about membership okay
so right now we've had four people sign
up during this stream which is quite
frankly a pretty poor showing I'm not
gonna lie but if we get six more people
who sign up it takes under a minute I'll
open up the phone lines and then maybe I
will finally get to speak to Stephen
Robin so let's see if we can make that
happen
okay a few other super chats here doctor
Galasso wits with a dollar ninety nine
super chat I appreciate that
holla Xin nothing more delicious than a
good raisin holla that's for sure kala
Xin says can you get a UFO researcher on
the show maybe maybe I just I don't know
how interesting that is to me quite
frankly and I don't know how interesting
it would be to my audience but I'd
consider that mic oh this is like Joe
Biden 300
three three oh three three oh mike 101
three one nine nine four oh and maybe
that's just October thirteenth nineteen
ninety-four sends a twenty five dollar
super chat saying debate Sam cedar oh
wait
right yeah that I'm not the person
you're supposed to be sending that to
Steven Robins also known as a Ronald
Reagan on other programs is a new
YouTube member just for kicks okay even
though the target is ten web site
members because Ronald Reagan is one of
them I'm gonna count that I'm gonna
count that and we are gonna up that to
five so if just five more people sign up
on my website you can see what that
looks like over here how do I become a
member join pakman.com join pakman.com
very easy join pakman.com takes you to
this page and then you can sign up see
mils five how do you feel about the
coverage of the amazon burning down
compared to the Notre Dame Notre Dame
Cathedral coverage seems off scale to me
personally of course I mean listen the
there's a couple factors at play there's
the factor at play of events with a
discrete beginning middle and end are
just much more media friendly so the
Amazon burning is part of a much bigger
story and I mean yeah so you're just
completely right the coverage is
ridiculous
the the g7 saying we're gonna commit 20
million to dealing with that as has been
pointed out on Twitter there are video
games with far larger budgets than what
is being committed by seven countries to
fight the fires and the it's absolutely
at the media coverage is ridiculous the
reactions are ridiculous it's all it's
all completely ridiculous okay let me
say thank you to okay we actually have a
bunch of things have we have got a bunch
of new members here let's see Justin
Quran is a new member that's number six
Spencer Nair is a new member that's
number seven and Salvador or Ballet hoe
is a new member that's number eight
Dusty Jones is a new member that's
number nine okay so now we're actually
making some progress here we are just
one new member
away from me opening up the phone line
so feel free to be number 10 the
progressive voice uu I knew that at some
point he was I actually think so he'll
have you been doing stuff on my twitch
streams but I just don't notice is that
something that's been going on because
somebody told me that you've been in my
twitch streams I haven't noticed you
thoughts on dry jacking what about
Andrew Luck retiring also do you think
kid buu is the strongest form of boo I
have no opinion about any of that stuff
other than Andrew Luck retiring
I completely listen I think football is
on a downward spiral I think football is
on in a death spiral
Andrew Luck retiring Gronk
Gronkowski talking today about or
yesterday about just like the the
psychological state that he was in as a
result of football it's I think football
is in a death spiral for a number of
different reasons Joseph Anderson also
signing up with a youtube membership and
I think that we are almost there as far
as new members go Dusty Jones oh no I
mentioned dusty Jones already wait a
second Austin Heller and Jimmy ba Rios
are new David Pakman show members
alright that gets us to 11 keep them
coming by all means let's open up the
phone lines here let me see if I can
just get things let me get set up here
for live calls let me think about the
right way to do it okay so we're gonna
go to this and then let me get the phone
line system set up the number is six one
seven eight three zero forty seven fifty
just give me a moment to enable the
phone lines okay you can start calling
in six one seven eight three zero 47 50
by the way if if if Ronald Reagan wants
to tell me what his area code is I'm
glad to go to him first just I normally
don't do this but I realized that he's
been trying to get on the
found with me for I think months at this
point so if someone wants to tell me if
he wants to tell me what his area code
is I'm glad to go to the phones and get
to Stephen first let me see here I'm
just getting connected we will very soon
here what is the number demo six one
seven eight three zero forty seven fifty
let's see 509 okay we're calling in to
the David Pakman show please do not use
speaker about setup have your question
ready and listen for David to call out
your area code
alright let me just get my notes set up
here always make I always take a bunch
of different notes so I know who is
calling okay all right let me go right
to them let me go to our caller from the
509 who I believe is potentially Steven
Robbins aka Ronald Reagan hey David
yes it's a pleasure to hear your voice
hey your studio set and a lot of people
are talking about it and you do it
better than Sam which i think is why he
you know I do hold on I do what I do
what better than said that he kind of
got in that respect and that's good on
you and bad on him right and frankly for
him that's embarrassing you think that
that's what it is either here o most
most definitely he's got like a little
sticker on his window right and you've
got the whole monitor and you can do
graphics and things like that so I'm
sure I do want to say that I actually I
like to do a lot of jokes and have sort
of a dry sense of humor but I'm going to
be serious
and say I really like your show
and populating now an demise YouTube you
know when I go to YouTube there's the
segments that you do sure
and I'm going to support your show I
think that you're great and keep up the
good work
Wow I mean if you are I don't know if
this is your dry humor or if you're
being serious but if you're being
serious I really appreciate that
no I'm being for real I yeah totally
sincere and I'm sorry for the the
joshing I hope you know that it was all
in good fun it of course was never meant
to be mean-spirited so and listen I
heard is it true that you speak Spanish
fluently yeah so I actually first heard
yes it's true I'm a former Mormon I did
my Mormon mission in the canary island
where I met alone a lot of arjen
Argentinian emerging times and that's
where I first heard this rumor from
Argentines that Hitler died in Argentina
what do you think about that I don't
believe that I think he I think we have
the right the official story on Hitler I
think there are certainly lots of other
Nazis who died in Argentina certainly
yeah well alright and you know somebody
on the majority report the other day
suggested a spanish-speaking sort of
progressive left-wing show jihad first
of all do you know of any content
creators out there already doing
something like that and no I'm
interested I know of a lunatic right
wing spanish-speaking political shows
but I actually am not aware of any good
leftist ones well you know let's do it
all right Stevens slash Ronald really
appreciate the call
are you all right take care very good
well so know the good news is that we've
got him now in our caller ID system and
then that'll all be that'll all be good
Michael Blasius says I called from 6 1 7
what happened I don't know I've taken
one call so far that's all nothing
happened yet alright let's go to our
caller from the five one six area code
who's calling from five one six today
five one six do you have us muted five
one six last opportunity alright five
one six is gone let's go to the four one
five area code who's calling today from
four one five hey David can you hear me
yeah who's this hey do you know Ortega
I'm from San Francisco California so I'm
only 17 years old and I've only been
really into politics for probably about
like three years now okay and I've
noticed that so many of the right
positions and like fundamental
philosophies or fundamental policy
positions are based on just like factual
inaccuracy and things that are just not
true like I'll come up to my friends or
to my dad or to other right-wing people
I know who are supports from or support
whoever and so many things they believe
this aren't aren't true and I like what
you mean exhibit them well sorry a
little bit cold here
um well they'll say that a vast majority
or a percentage of Latin American
immigrants commit violent crime or that
okay and he's gone very good
I don't know if he hung up because he
didn't have another example or we lost
connection I don't know what that was
about
the number for people asking is six one
seven eight three zero 4750 let's go
this will be special let's go to country
code 52 who's calling today from country
code 52 hello yes that's you what would
go does country code 52 hello David my
name is Santiago and I'm from Mexico
City Oh brilliant what's going on
Santiago
sorry I'm a little bit nervous it's okay
that's good that works in my event I
would like to congratulate you on having
the show 2016 and you and Calculon you
have important me about this politics
and that's why I now support Bernie
Sanders even though I'm a Mexican
citizen and okay yeah I would like to
ask you a question regarding Trump I saw
your video about the censorship that
that leaked executive order was was you
know sent to the media and my biggest
fear is that for example we have a new
president which is Amal oh and he has
had several authoritarian decisions and
my question is you think that
authoritarian decision or zoning
decisions that are fetched compacts made
it could trickle down to Mexico to Latin
America and especially for example in
Argentina with Krishna probably
returning to power yeah I mean listen I
don't know if it's a trickle down per se
I think it's part of the broader
nationalist authoritarian movements that
we've seen particularly in Europe and
there could be contagion in Latin
America as well I don't know that it's
so direct and in Latin America it tends
to be more sort of pseudo left populist
authoritarianism it's like a different
flavor than the right-wing nationalist
stuff that we see so yeah I mean to some
extent but I don't know that it's it's
sort of like a little bit that it's
gonna translate quite so literally okay
well we have say that what happens in
America occurs in Mexico a couple of
years later so that's kind of a casual
thing it certainly seems to be happening
with obesity interestingly enough yeah
that happened yeah thank you very much
for your time okay muchas gracias
okay Santiago great to hear from him
Mexico City we're taking calls at 6 1 7
8 3 0 47 50 let's go to our caller from
the six-30 area code who's calling from
six-30 today yeah that's you oh hey hey
David this is I Adam hey I'm not gonna
be I'm from the Chicago suburbs
brilliant what's going on I had a couple
questions for you I think I think I'll
you answered the first one I mean
whether it would be more as a centrist
candidate or a progressive Kim it would
be the best option for beating Trump
next year and the second one I was
wondering if you yourself would ever
consider running for political office
any time you know maybe maybe in a knee
or in the distant future you know I've
been approached about running I don't
even want to say for what because of
that but just even say there's just no
reason to say for what it's irrelevant
because I'm not doing it right but I
mean listen if I were to do it I would
have to figure out first of all could I
do it could I do more good if I were to
win then what I can do on the show and
the show has a sizable audience now and
to bail on that would be you know a big
big decision and I would need to I mean
listen the truth is that what keeps me
from really taking it seriously is the
amount of oversight that there would be
over what I'm doing as an elected
official and you know I run my business
I do what I want I say what I want and
it doesn't mean there are no
repercussions obviously there are but
there's not oversight in that same way
and so I don't know absolutely no
question about it
yeah and you know there's people in the
chat saying I could do both but it's
like not really if you're a full-time
I've already been running for City
Council that's part time right I mean
I'd be doing it and it would be a
serious position and I would want to
make sure that I could use my audience
to propel me in a sense and I would want
to use the audience I've built to help
me get to that office if I were to do it
and so there would need to be a lot of
it I would literally need to do an
actual exploratory committee to look at
all aspects
okay you wouldn't necessarily rule
without but but it's not something that
you consider in the near future then
thought would never rule anything out
that would be very silly too right yeah
right all right well thank you for
taking my call I appreciate it okay Adam
Adam from Chicago great to hear from you
appreciate that let's go next to our
caller from the 908 area code who's
calling today from 908 by the way the
phone is working beautifully today hey
David hey Mike what's going on hey so
I'm curious about your thoughts on the
national debt and what implications that
has for our country can you be a little
more specific do you mean like just the
implications of like having debt for all
this debt and do you think it's a
negative thing II think it's problem if
we go further into debt which we
obviously are yeah so there's a not a
simple answer to this I mean here's the
thing first of all in terms of dollars
we could be further and further in debt
but as a percentage of the economy it
could remain the same if the economy
keeps growing the national debt could
keep growing in dollars but not
represent a bigger and bigger part of
the economy does that part at least make
sense uh that does make sense
sure good so just like as a starting
point the number of dollars of debt
doesn't tell us whether we're in trouble
or not the second thing is when we talk
about deficit spending not every dollar
of deficit spending is created equal so
we could imagine reasons in the same way
that a household can go into debt for a
mortgage versus going to debt to pay for
a vacation those would not be equally
advantageous financially a country can
deficit spend for good reasons or bad
reasons would you sort of grant that at
least yes sure and even beyond that
there's stimulative investment and not
stimulative investment so my view on the
debt is I don't have a problem with
carrying debt the idea that at some
point we're going to need to pay it all
off is not very likely and that
nightmare scenario doesn't seem to be
likely I'm okay deficit spending for
things that would be stimulus
to the economy getting everybody
healthcare even though I don't think we
actually need to I think a lot of the
proposals pay for themselves but
ignoring that for a second I don't think
it makes sense to deficit spend to give
really rich people tax cuts which
they'll mostly put in the bank for
example so my that's I don't have like
it just a view which is like the debt is
good or the debt is bad well if you give
private individuals money won't they
like if you say rich P I'm not really
for giving bigger tax cuts but when they
invest the money in the economy anyway
so that would just be another form of
adding investment all Fiat private yes
but the the point is that there
depending on who you give the money to
they do different things with it because
of a concept called the marginal
propensity to consume and just stuffing
the money away in a bank account does
not have the same stimulative effect as
for example investing in a local
business as an example or spending it in
your local community so you still even
in that case you have to distinguish
between who gets the money
what is being invested if it goes in a
bank right because it's being went out
to other people either for consumption
or for their business endeavors maybe a
small business it is that's the primary
way in which that's the primary way in
which money on paper or in a computer is
created but the stimulative effect of
that has been studied versus other types
of of spending or investment and it's
not nearly as advantageous I'll concede
that I don't know enough to refute you
on that all right very good
I'd really like to see the bate debate a
debate Gavin I'd do it on your show I
would sorry got it Gavin who Gavin
McInnes Oh Oh Gavin McInnes okay gotcha
okay all right I will consider that
thank you thank you all right take care
let me read a couple of other super
chats that came in Matthew Dominguez
wants to know if I will break down and
reacts climate policy I plan to Alice
angle heart is a new YouTube member Tico
Todd sent me 2,500 Costa Rican something
let's look up what that is in US dollars
CRC 2 USD Costa Rican colonna's is oh
four dollars and 40 cents
okay wow there's been some some currency
devaluation there it seems actually now
in fact the the costa rican cologne
seems to have gained value over the last
six months in any case i appreciate that
e sends a five dollar super chat
thoughts on polling that warren
supporters are mostly college-educated
upper middle class and bernie is
supported widespread lower middle class
base i have that bookmarked i have not
looked at it in detail yet let me thank
a couple of other new members rafael
Calderon Matt Dominguez Paloma Rene and
I believe I already thanked Jimmy
Barrios and Austin Heller really
appreciate it okay glad I was able to
get the phone lines opened I'm out of
time but I do plan on streaming again
later this week on Twitch okay the next
stream this week is on twitch twitch dot
TV slash david pakman twitch.tv slash
david pakman subscribe there with Amazon
Prime via twitch Prime I'll be streaming
there next time and it's going to be a
big party I hope to see you there